I think one of the things we're seeing
you know is
um is there's been a general feeling in
the United States of lack of control and
control and the feeling of control is a
remarkable thing and how it affects
human beings
um there was there were these studies
done in the
1970s in the UK called the Whitehall
studies
and they wanted these social scientists
want to understand this thing that they
labeled executive stress syndrome
right which the Assumption was the more
senior you get the more responsibility
you have the more impact your decisions
can make the more stress that that that
puts upon you so they did the study in
government in Whitehall because they
could control for variances in health
care because everybody got the same
um and here's what they discovered the
more senior you get your stress goes
down
yes you have more responsibility yes the
stakes are higher but you also have more
agency you get to decide how to spend
your day you get to have more control
over how you solve a problem and when
you're in the most Junior position you
have the least amount of agency because
somebody tells you what to do and you're
going to do it this way and there is no
creativity and there is no there is no
variability and it's the lack of control
that actually increases diabetes heart
disease and some cancers right a
phenomenon that has happened again I
blame the past 30 40 years where you
know people give their entire lives to a
company and then get the proverbial gold
watch there's an entire generation that
when we talk about the gold watch they
don't know what we're talking about
uh because this doesn't exist anymore
and if you think about it and again
because of the the commonality the
frequency of of the use of layoffs as a
as a as a tool right we all I'm for
those who saw the better.com video I
don't know if you saw it it was
embarrassing you know the CEO made a
video that he played to employees that
over Zoom so what do you fired 900
people 900 people with a video saying if
if you're unlucky enough to be seeing
this video and effective immediately you
know two weeks before Christmas and when
the CFO was interviewed about it he said
well we need to and I love this
terminology we need to Fortress the
balance sheet like this is why we should
not let CFOs like talk to the public
fairly
uh but the point the point is is is
um is what he what he Amplified
is that if you have your own business if
you're a small business owner you know
you're going to go out of business
months before like no small business
owner goes to work one day thinking
everything's fine then the next day
there's nothing right it just doesn't
exist
but we now live in a society where
having a stable job with benefits could
end
tomorrow effective immediately yeah is
what they were told not a meritocracy no
fault of my own the company is doing
well
and so if you think about how twisted
that is that a quote unquote stable job
is actually not stable at all
and that stress sits with every single
employee you said we need to have a
meeting and fear is the first reaction
says something not necessarily about the
company but it says something about
business yeah and the way business and
Corporate America is viewed
um
and so uh the question is is what can we
as companies do to make people feel
and have agency one of the ways is
accountability right which is you have
responsibility for this project
if it goes right I will give you credit
and if it goes wrong I will stand by you
and support you as you try and mend it
right I'm not swooping in
right I'm not swooping in and I'm not
taking the credit and and we give people
control and this is a huge mistake
that's made in leadership all the time
which is all the all the authority sits
at the top all the information sits at
the bottom this is David Marquez work
and many falsely believe we have to push
information up so that decisions can be
made which is if inefficient and it
never really happens
but the real responsibility is to push
Authority down and now go back to the
Marine Corps you know commander's intent
the company wants to go in this
direction and we would like to
accomplish this how would you like to
solve that problem like customer service
I mean take something really basic you
know
um which I find fascinating the number
of senior Executives who sit in a room
to fix a customer service problem and
yet why are there no Frontline employees
in that room because there's one group
of people who knows much more about
customer service than anybody else in
the company and it's the people who talk
to the customers every day
[Applause]